في الاستوديو ينضم لنا الدكتور محمد نبيل
مهنا اخصائي امراض الغدد الصماء والسكري
دكتور اهلا بك معنا في مساء العربيه اولا
هل يصح ان يصوم مرض السكري من النوع الاول
او الثاني اهلا وسهلا بكم بالساده
المشاهدين وكل سنه وانتم طيبين طبعا
مرضى السكر بينقسموا للنوع الاول والنوع
الثاني طبعا مش اي مريض ينفع ان هو يصوم
يعني قبل بدايه الشهر الكريم المفروض ان
المريض بيزور الطبيب المعالج بتاعه علشان
يحدد اذا كان المريض فتل للصيام ولا لا
فبنقسم المرضى لاربع مجاميع ففي المجموعه
الاولى اللي هي شديده الخطوره جدا ودي
يعني ممنوع منعا تاما ان هم يصوموا ودول
طبعا اللي هم مرضى السكر من النوع الاول
على اساس ان مرضى السكر من النوع الاول
دول بياخدوا الانسولين اربع مرات في اليوم
او بيكون المريض على مضخه انسولين فطبعا
بيكون معرض لارتفاعات وانخفاضات في
مستويات السكر في الدم ودي طبعا بتشكل
ممكن خطوره حياه المريض وفي نفس الوقت مع
عدد ساعات الصيانه الطويله والجفاف ممكن
ده يؤدي الى تكوين احماض كيتونيه دي ممكن
تؤدي الى غيبوبه سكر الدكتور محمد هل في
حالات او اعراض تظهر على مريض السكري
الصائم عليه ان يقطع صيامه فورا طبعا هو
المريض يقطع صيامه فورا لو حس بارتفاع او
انخفاض في مستويات السكر في الدم لو في
ارتفاع في مستويات السكر في الدم وهو شيك
بالجلوكوميتر ولها قياس السكر فوق ال 300
فلازم ان هو طبعا يفطر فورا او لو حصل
انخفاض في السكر تحت السبعين فبرده
المفروض ان هو يفطر فورا وطبعا هو بيشيك
لو حس بالاعراض زي ما حضرتك ذكرتي
والاعراض يعني اعراض الارتفاع في مستوى
السكر في الدم العطش الزائد فرط التبول
ممكن دوخه الام في البطن
تمام والاعراض بتاعه الانخفاض بتتمثل فيه
دقات القلب السريعه اول دوخه
فلو حس بدقات قلب سريعه او دوخه فممكن ان
هو يشك ان في انخفاض في مستويات السكر متى
لايون صح طبيا
المرضى السكري من النوع الاول او الثاني
بالصف المرضى السكر من النوع الاول
المفروض ان هو ما يصومش لان هو خلاص يعني
ده الموضوع فيه ريسك كبير لكن لو مريض
السكر من النوع الثاني وبياخد بس ادويه
حبوب فهو طبعا ممكن ان هو يصوم اذا كان
برده السكر كنترول والتراكمي بتاعه السبعه
فممكن ان هو يصوم بطريقه امنه شكرا جزيلا
لك في الاستوديو الدكتور محمد نبيل شكرا
جزيلا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات